Donald Trump's former White House communications
director, Anthony Scaramucci, has again admitted
something which I've been covering for years
at this point, which is that Donald Trump
has difficulty reading.
He really doesn't read and he struggles to
read.
Anthony scaramouch, he has been doing interviews
recently.
He's been more honest than maybe we are used
to hearing from people who worked for Trump
or who work for Trump.
And he's admitted to a number of things, including
that Donald Trump can't read very well.
Check out this clip from an interview with
a non-ID Geary Dhara Das, who's been a previous
guest on the David Pakman show as well.
I'm not I'm not a I'm not a diagnostician,
but my guess is that he probably had an undiagnosed
learning disability as a kid.
Maybe it's a form of dyslexia or something
like that.
And so his reading comprehension levels are
not where his IQ probably is.
Okay.
Now he's in decline right now, but you'd have
to stipulate that he's a reasonably smart
guy.
I mean, he built a business, he built a television
show, he made a name for himself.
And in 17 short months, he went from being
a reality television star to the presidency
of the United States.
So we have to stipulate that there's intelligence
in there.
But it's what kind of intelligence?
So scaramouch, he is obviously not saying
it in as definitive or aggressive terms as
we have suggested before.
But scaramouch, he also knows that Trump struggles
to read.
And he makes it clear there this is not making
fun of people.
This is not making fun of learning disabilities.
This is simply pointing out, don't we need
a president who can read well and regularly
reads?
We suspect Trump hasn't read a book in his
adult life.
There is no evidence that Trump has read a
book in his adult life.
He's never mentioned reading anything other
than his own book, Art of the Deal, which
he didn't write.
Tony Schwartz wrote it.
And the Bible, which, you know, if you believe
Trump, read the Bible.
OK, I may have a bridge to sell you.
But remember that I've been covering this
for years and there is interest in it and
a lot of agreement back in February of twenty
seventeen, we did a story called Trump Fails
Basic Literacy Test.
It got nearly 3.4 million views on YouTube
and other 7 million on Facebook.
This was subsequently picked up around the
world, including in France and other countries.
And it explains a lot now that not being able
to read well doesn't mean Trump's a bad person.
Not being able to read well doesn't mean Trump
is wrong on policy.
He is usually wrong on policy, but for other
reasons.
But it explains a lot.
To quote Donald Trump, including things like
this from earlier this week, John DICKERSON
Hall Logic and SFA Fefe Saffa hide this reading
deficit has been widely corroborated, Saturday
Night Live's Pete Davidson said when Trump
was hosting SNL. Trump couldn't seem to read
the scripts.
I've played this clip for you before.
What happened with the Trump stock?
So he's like, he doesn't really know how to
read for real.
Yeah, and he loves to improve.
So during the table read he like before like
we were going to read even before he had to
read each line.
And he's the host so he's at everything.
Yeah.
He would go oh I'm not going to say this or
they would say it the way I want to say is
it OK to learn everything every like one.
And then this is my favorite part is there
is a sketch that we wrote where he's at Disneyland
with his daughter and the line is.
All right, let's get out of here.
Turkey legs like it's like, go get your legs
over.
He doesn't know how to read.
So he went, all right, good.
Get out of here.
Turkey leg.
He called his daughter eggs.
That was his impro.
Oh, no.
And then he looked at me.
He doesn't get it like he thinks.
Everybody's laughing with him, but we're all
laughing at him.
So that's not new.
We've covered that previously.
No.
Casler worked with Trump on The Apprentice
and says Trump couldn't read, although with
no casler it seemed maybe it was more about
Trump's inability to sit still rather than
simply not being able to read.
No casler.
You know, we've heard about the possible upas
stuff with The Apprentice.
So the point is, we know from sources inside
the White House, Trump's presidential daily
briefings have been reduced from what's normally
many pages of text to just a couple of pages
to just one page to just one page.
That is half charts and graphs.
And even that Trump is accepting with low
frequency.
So this is not good.
And the reason it's not good is because it's
tough to be informed if you're not reading
a lot as president.
That's how Barack Obama was informed.
That's how George does.
George W. Bush read a lot?
He read no political material.
He also just read books.
We know that doesn't mean Bush is a great
guy.
Doesn't mean he was a great president.
But he was reading at least he came to many
wrong decisions.
But he was reading Bill Clinton spent a ton
of time reading intelligence, reporting books,
et cetera.
Trump simply doesn't do it.
And all politics aside, that's a fundamental
liability when you're president of the United
States.
It's sad more than anything, but it has a
real effect on Trump's ability to be a leader.
And it's not a good effect.
I'll tell you that right now